hi I'm buzz and I'm Barrett now
something is happening in the world of
Agriculture call it soil Health
sustainable farming maybe even
regenerative agriculture however you
want to label it it's happening and soil
scientist Dr Ray wild describes it like
this I think we're in a stage now I
actually think we're in a revolution
it's just a you know such an exciting
time to be in agriculture
after really A Century of Agriculture
kind of going downhill production going
up but in a very unsustainable way and
actually in a way that isn't even
sustaining Farmers so the average age of
farmers kept creeping up so it's in the
60s now and now we're entering a period
where some of the uh leading innovative
Farmers definitely the farmers are
leading this so part of the controversy
is that the scientists are are chasing
behind and and you know these things
seem to work can we explain why they're
working we don't know there's a lot we
don't know which makes science exciting
if we knew it all we retire right and
this is what's making so many farmers
and ranchers in South Dakota excited and
nrcs state conservationist Jeff zdge
gets it I got a chance to be out out in
the field I got a chance to visit with
our staff got a chance to visit with
producers and just seeing this
incredible interest in this topic it
just seemed to me like what was going to
be able to make our state successful was
if we had the healthiest soils possible
and so I really believe it's the most
important thing we can focus on so soil
health is a slam dunk right well not
quite and the big picture is that no
till acreage is still climbing and South
Dakota but it's not across the board
we've seen a leveling off in some
counties and even a loss of no till
acreage in others and that also has
Jeff's attention so the first thing is
we got to start finding out why right
and pretty much anytime that you get out
amongst producers there's going to be
folks that are going to
go well yeah it could work there but it
won't work on my farm and here's why and
so we heard issues like um my soils are
too wet my soils are too cold I have too
much residue um I can't plant that
rotation because that's not economical
for me and the list goes on while we
heard those things it gets kind of
perplexing because you look right across
the road and then there's a producer
that's doing it and being very
successful so this whole idea of trying
to research this stuff bring together
the researchers bring together the
people who are doing it on the landscape
and try to really dig deeper and kind of
find out if we can explain maybe why
they're concerned about it but maybe why
they're concerned about it is not real
true and so our job is to do the deeper
digging we'll be speaking to people in
the lab and on the land and we'll be the
guys asking Merit or myth we'll post
this material as videos blogs Vlogs and
podcasts and now I'm really getting
excited we look forward to visiting with
you all at Merit or myth stay tuned
because this will be fun f